alors à vous sortez votre quatrième
album solo ça s'appelle soldats de
fortune c'est sur un label indépendant
qui s'appelle 361 henry corde vous êtes
fâchés avec les majeures non par
elle-même puisque la yam on a resigné
chez une major n'a signé chez polydor
mais je trouve que c'est bien de
connaître deux aspects différents de du
business de la musique alors c'est un
album solo on retrouve quand même à
l'intérieur tous les membres de iam
pourquoi faire un album solo ou alors
c'est parce qu'au départ j'étais parti
sur une configuration de faire un street
album une mixtape c'était vraiment pour
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas le
street album où la miss fcd
je traduis
ce sont des albums beaucoup moins
ambitieux avec beaucoup moins de budget
qui sortent vraiment sans promo
saharienne donc j'étais parti sur ça et
au bout de quinze titres on a décidé de
basculer dans un album donc c'était
vraiment open studio comme un open bar
tout le monde rentrait ouais j'aime bien
ce titre up je poussais un couple est à
moi
voilà il ya beaucoup d'invités dessus du
coup c'est plutôt bien alors c'est un
album qui est quand même beaucoup moins
sombre que le précédent pour lequel vous
étiez venu la solitude à jeter venu
juste après deux tours jumelles c'était
super sympa
donc beaucoup d'électro quand même
je suis venu au hip hop à travers à
travers le d'abord par une musique
festive qui était jouée avec des
instruments fin des années 70 début des
années 80 et ensuite l'électro donc c
est mon mon fond on va dire formation au
niveau du hip hop ça a été ça l'itc de
musique là alors il est choisi pour cet
album l'imagerie du vietnam le titre ces
soldats de fortune alors c'est qu'ils
ennemis
l'ennemi et il n'a pas de visage
aujourd'hui on vit dans une société où
le conflictuelle de partout dans le
monde en vue des conflits on nous sommes
d'y participer ou du moins si on n'y
participent pas nous sommes de choisir
notre camp et c'est vrai et je pense
qu'on a une majorité en france mais
aussi dans des pays du moyen orient des
pays d'asie où on n'a pas envie de
choisir entre un show d'occident et le
facho du moyen-orient donc on est des
sommets de fortune c'est à dire mais
notre combat pour le bien on ne parle
même pas de ni de religion ni de dogmes
religieux mais juste entre le bien et le
mal avec les armes qu'on a c'est pas
dans le sens mercenaires ça je voulais
vraiment préciser parce que aux états
unis a soldier of fortune c'est des
mercenaires dont c'est pas du tout
tout ça alors vous dites le monde vit
une révolution de droite ça veut dire
quoi ça c'est à dire que quand la droite
fait sa révolution elle le fait avec du
pognon et descend pas dans la rue
leur évolution de droite c'est quand ya
des entreprises qui font des 60 70 % de
bénéfices à l'année qui lourd de dix
mille personnes ça c'est la révolution
de droite et après qu'il faut en croire
aux gens et aux gens qui n'ont pas
d'argent que c'est eux qui doivent faire
les forums premier je trouve ça un peu
déplacé si la roue elle doit tourner la
roue de l'histoire le tourner c'est pas
toujours les gens qui ont pas les moyens
qui doivent faire le premier pas
toujours la pêche a toujours toujours
plus qu'avant on aimerait vous salir en
forme ouais ouais c'est les enfants
c'est enfin si je me lève tôt je prends
un peu soin de soi non moi je fais je
vais pas de crème de nuit quand même non
je suis peut-être mais j'ai changé des
coûts voilà bah tu vois même alors là
qu'est la situation sur ce rôle
cette cadillac et nathan dit moi je
change les couches donc là je mène à
l'école
moi aussi je mène à l'école alors
pourquoi justement il n'y a pas eu
d'émeutes à marseille parce que
marseille est une ville particulière au
niveau de l'identité en tout cas les
marseillais en ce côté c'est dur à dire
mais oui c'est ça ne te marseillais
avant d'être français n'y a pas l'y a
pas de
pierre d'adtoma mais vraiment mais
vraiment et aussi merci c'était une
ville qui vit énormément de
du temps où il y avait les colonies donc
à la décolonisation c'est une ville qui
s'effondrait industriellement haut
niveau de
l'état créé un secteur tertiaire énorme
pour sinon aujourd'hui on aurait 30 % et
32 % de chômage à marseille donc en
parallèle à celle s'est développé
énormément d'associations les
associations entier ont tissé une sorte
de filet sur toute la ville et je vous
garantis que les gens sur le terrain
c'est souvent on me dit où il des hommes
politiques veulent me rencontrer où on
me demande mais alors vous avez fait du
bon boulot en mars et j'y vais c'est pas
moi si vous voulez rencontrer des gens
bien vous en présente 23 et forcément
ils n'ont pas trop envie de rencontrer
le ils veulent rencontrer du people
il ya aussi le grand banditisme et ouais
je voulais pas trop en parler oui ça
existe oui oui ça existe le g c'est
aussi ça tient quand même parce que si
tu brûles une caisse là où ça va les
voitures ne brûle pas voilà voilà ouais
mais à marseille je pense quand même il
ya la volonté toujours de prendre le
contre-pied de paris moi ça me frappe
parce que je suis un peu comme ça
marseillais d'adoption il ya une haine
de paris très forte dans l'impression
des émeutes déployés d'avoir à marseille
le jour où ce sera très calme à paris
quoi s'est il y en a eu il y en a eu
dans les années 80 d'ailleurs les
sociologues des lois qui disait que
marseille avait 20 ans au niveau social
j'ai eu des gros et m au début des
années 80 il avait fait il y avait des
citations esaü en plus des des émeutes
ethniques où il y avait eu des sortes de
guérilla entre les gitans les arabes
avaient été bien choisi c'est un bon
laboratoire je trouve pour la france
parce que marseille ait pas de ghetto a
enfin cessé il ya des quartiers très
différents les quartiers qu'ailleurs oui
bien sûr il n'y a pas le côté comme à
paris c'est à dire les ghettos sur les
côtés ou dans l'à beaucoup de grandes
villes c'est pas une grande ville
occidentale c'est à dire avec un
centre-ville très riche et les quartiers
oui mais
bien que new york ça change et les
promoteurs ils sont même passés sur
harlem centre a découvert le rap en
partant à new york c'est voir ton oncle
vent à moi j'ai toute ma famille nous y
aurait miami los angeles elle hérite
altucher alors tu es musulman doit oui
tu as réagi comment aux caricatures de
mahomet je les trouve aussi l'aide qu'il
caricature qui était fait sur les juifs
dans les années 30 dans le money près
nazi je trouve que c'est un cessez de
ces racistes c'est gratuit et ça
n'arrange rien à la situation c'est pour
ça que je dis à travers ce genre de
caricatures là on nous somme de choisir
notre cas donc il ya des caricatures
pourquoi s'il avait vraiment envie de
caricaturer pourquoi ils n'ont pas pris
les mollahs ils pouvaient encore
caricaturer ahmadinéjad où les mots là
ça pose aucun problème du moment
caricaturant mao mais on prend tous les
musulmans et on les met tous dans le
même sac et c'est ce que je dis des fois
on a l'impression depuis septembre 2001
moi j'étais impressionné fois de me
réveiller le matin et un mollah omar qui
dort à côté de mon avis c'est un fait
chier comme ça il me regarde j'ai envie
de me débarrasser
quand j'ai quand j'étais quand j'étais
jeune à la fin des années soixante dix
il y avait un type un dessinateur qui
s'appelait gotlib et je me souviens j'ai
été nourri par ça et et chez les bandes
dessinées de gotlib que c'était c'était
il y avait tous les dieux il y avait il
y avait moïse y avait du l'oeil avait il
y avait mahomet il y avait jésus-christ
et il faisait 10 d'immenses partout il
se bourrer la gueule et tout et personne
ne disait rien personne n'était
scandalisé moi je suis très frappé par
sa mère tout le monde se marrait tout le
monde se marrait jus d'accord avec toi
quand tu dit scandalisé parce que ces
caricatures moi je trouve nulle ridicule
sert à rien mais en même temps en même
temps en avion paris pense qu'on est
dans une région on est dans une société
où ce genre de il ya des gens qui ont le
droit qui doivent pouvoir avoir le droit
de publier ces caricatures et voilà
c'est ça le je crois le débat qui a
dansé que moi par exemple au point quand
on a vu ces caricatures on a dit
benjamin va publier ça c'est pas bien on
a pas les publier d'accord mais en tant
d'autres journaux doivent avoir le droit
de les publier sans que ça fasse
d'histoire moi je trouve ça on vit quand
même dans des sociétés on doit pouvoir
tout dire et tout faire
mais bon là ça c'est vrai quand il ya
des gens qui ont envie de le faire
qu'ils le fassent après j'aimerais bien
que l'opinion publique au nom de la
liberté d'expression nailloux pas dans
une opinion qui est libertaire au départ
et qui finit par être fascisante à la
fin le dal même dans le traitement de
l'information on voit que médiatiquement
le meurtre de chaïb qui a eu ces
derniers jours qui te meurtre raciste a
fait un soir de une information et il ya
vraiment un problème il ya un problème
général justement parlé d'un enfant que
je vais venir en aide à l'émission de
vulgarisation sur l'islam on a sept
millions de musulmans en france jamais
le film le message est un film de paix
avec
anthony quinn il n'est jamais passé ne
serait ce que sur le service public on a
un problème on a un petit problème qui
est qui et à régler moi j'accepte qui
est déjà un thé qui ne croient pas en
dieu faut que les gens acceptent aussi
qui est des gens qui peuvent être
blessés déjà on vous savait par exemple
mes beaux-parents qui sait des gens vous
venez chez eux ils dorment par terre
pour vous laisser dormir dans leurs lits
ils vous reçoivent chez eux mais
vraiment c'est l'hospitalité ces
caricatures ces caricatures les hommes
blessés ne serait ce que pour ces gens
là ne serait ce que pour les gens là
j'aurais aimé que déjà un ce truc en
goodies ces caricatures c'est vraiment
des caricatures
on est d'accord il faut croyez pas de
situer le problème pia je pense que ce
que je comprends pas d'ailleurs souvent
dans une partie du monde musulman qui a
une attitude victimaire et guy non non
non on doit pas faire ça mais bien
entendu est d'ailleurs le monde musulman
n'aurait pas gueuler c'est caricatural
et demi de personnes en avaient parlé et
je trouve ça a été beaucoup mieux qu'on
n'en parle pas comme d'ailleurs on ne
parle pas de certaines caricatures sur
l'album en aux musulmans qui avait
laissé les gens qui ressemblent aux gens
qui font la caricature non je voulais
même d'en face à tan tan je parle pas du
monde musulman en france je parle du
monde musulman enfin toutes ces
manifestations qui a eu lieu dans ces
pays là
dassieu je ne crois pas que ce qui a de
plus insultant pour l'islam beaucoup
plus que les caricatures c'est les types
kim qui donne des images à la télévision
quand il égorge des des otages au nom de
l'islam tu crois pas que c'est beaucoup
plus insultant pour l'islam et il était
beau parent lui doivent être beaucoup
plus humiliés et beaucoup plus
instrument d omar ces gens là bas ou que
par un caricaturiste en anglais on
n'aime pas on en parle on le dit pas
pourquoi les musulmans ne disent pas
pourquoi il se révolte contre ces gens
là rien sur qui les disaient mais le
problème le système médiatique est telle
qu'on a en france donne
99,9 pour cent du temps de parole à ces
gens là où du temps d'image à ces gens
là ont médiatisé la peur aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui est média utilisé sur
l'islam pourquoi arrive l'islam à quel
moment ils viennent dans l'histoire des
religions a lancé j'ai lu marcel gaucher
mois donc à quel moment à toi je sais
que ça revient après la grande
transgression chrétienne s'est passé pas
innocent c'est une réforme du site une
réforme de la 2de la chrétienneté mais
ça c'est bien ces grandes religions
monothéistes c'est le grand shiva
aujourd'hui la chasse dans la france
profonde beaucoup déjà on va papa pas
l'image d'eads et des terroristes et des
otages y crois que ça y est c'est me
tracé qui doit sa queue et tu sais bien
on le voit d'ailleurs on le voit
marseille on le voit à paris moi je sais
pas ce que j'ai une amie musulmane un
jour elle avait un problème affreux
comme ça dans sa vie qui est souvent la
première église est allé prier le même
dieu mais c'est ça qu'ils foutent médias
les musulmans que vous recevez des
sciences avec l'islam on en parle
souvent à travers des des choses sont en
relative aux jamais que des choses
positives alors quand le rappeur
monsieur r 10 la france est une garce
n'oublie pas de la baiser jusqu'à
l'épuiser comme une [ __ ] je suis pas
d'accord avec cette
même même si il a envie de
de passer un message moi je connais
monsieur r je pense que c'est que ces
phrases là je reconnais pas là la
personne que j'aime bien à ces phases là
mais malheureusement il s'instaure une
sorte de marketing direct du choc et de
la peur est que que certaines
oui mais oui du marketing de la
marketing france mais marketing de la
haine des immigrés aussi
en europe
et je pense que c'est ça qui est quand
le français dans ce sens il si j'ai bien
situer c'est une partie de ping pong
tout à fait c'est une partie de ping
pong local auquel ouais il faut arrêter
mais il faut pas excusé justement les
hommes politiques d'une responsabilité
au delà des rappeurs les propos de
monsieur sarkozy ce week-end sur
lamentable quand il dit qu est une bande
de jeunes torturent un jeune homme
jusqu'à jusqu'à le tuer le mot racaille
bien faible il prend deux situations où
il ya eu un acte de banditisme suivi de
nac de de racisme où il ya un jeune
homme qui se fait tuer il prend sa
visite à argenteuil où il ya des gamins
de 16 ans qui l'insultent sur le parvis
qui fait il mélange et le jette à l'eau
visage de la france en disant finalement
dans les quartiers des tortionnaires
potentiel non mais c'est exactement ça
c'est pareil excusez-moi catcheur et
attire carlier qui qui a une émission
qui est quand même une personne
intelligente il est c'est ça c'est nous
sommes censés être bête et pas avoir
fait d'études c'est une personne
intelligente il reçoit un ancien
skinhead sur le plateau qui dit mieux -
le ça y est j'ai trouvé ma paie je me
suis converti à l'islam jeune femme
marocaine j'ai bien j'ai trouvé mon
équilibre et il dit faudrait pas
basculer d'une extrême à une autre mais
tu te rends compte sur la même ligne et
cette personne là mais la religion
musulmane et les skinheads d'extrême
droite
c'est gravissime de dire des choses
comme ça et voulait pas qu'on se sente
choqué nous on répond avec un emballage
différent de monsieur r mais
fermement radicalement aussi il faut
qu'il faut que ce pays-là réalise qu'on
est là parce que sinon je ne me voyais
pas aussi que c'est l'islam doit faire
sa révolution
c'est à dire qu'il doit ce dernier à la
modernité de la tournée dure individus
au nez du temps d'enfin motte depuis
quarante-six france a mis deux cent
cinquante ans a fait sa révolution il
faut donner du temps c'est pas de
l'argent qu'ils ont une idée comme ça
c'est vrai mais c'est une révolution
nécessaire il faut que bien sûr que les
intellectuels musulmans fassent la
révolution il ya déjà été dans
l'histoire de rumeurs a échoué non elle
est là elle n'a pas échoué elle a
basculé au xiiie siècle avec moi
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu